all right so sake one let's start with
you first just in terms of help people
understand when you came out of college
it was pretty well known that you were
gonna be
uh you know selected very high everyone
knew hey this guy's for real on the
field
uh but i think you've always had this
interest in kind of business and
investing and really trying to
understand
stuff off the field as well how much uh
what i'll call like
traditional education either the nfl or
other people really provided versus have
you had to figure out some of this stuff
on your own
well you're kind of going in and out but
i i think i got the gist of the question
um when you first come out the league uh
i mean
well let's start in college you know you
have success uh you see where you're
able to go on the draft board and you
know that
um you can break that that curse in your
family um of cour of creating
uh wealth in your family and uh you
start thinking what can i do
uh what's the safest way um you know
obviously i won't be more
than football players so you start
asking questions obviously you hire a
financial advisor
um to be completely honest um you know
had no clue
about what i was going to do or uh
things that i can do
and when i got to nfl to help my money
um
grow and to invest and i was very
fortunate enough to to find an amazing
team with gopointed amazing manager who
put me in the right positions and
put me in contact with with godzilla you
and jack
um and to be able to have those
conversations continue to learn and
um you know nfl pa they do a little bit
of stuff
uh when you're in nfl when you come into
college they're like
there's like a seminar um when you have
you have and
they bring x players and they bring
people in the talk but
you really just learn about um what not
to do with your money
um don't buy these cars don't buy this
house don't do this don't do that
it's basically just scaring you the same
thing like
the realization that yes you may have a
lot of money but
um especially after taxes um it's really
not as much of the same and
you want to find the best way to to save
and that was the the
the gist of what i was what i was taught
and um
what i've learned so far coming and
coming out of nfl
and into my rookie year and so on yeah
and so uh i know you've got this
interested in kind of investing in uh
and private companies now
uh talk a little bit just about like why
you're personally interested in that and
kind of what have you done
uh in that space um
you know you see the the kds the lebrons
um
the bradys of the world um and you know
you want to create generational wealth
um and you can't do that just off of um
you know especially
in a sport that i play in the position i
play and coming off an injury
um you know that's kind of stuff that
that kind of makes more sense
when you sit out of football for a whole
year you realize that this game could be
taken away from you and
make you sit back and think damn if i
never played down a football ball right
now
this is how much i haven't um that's not
enough for generational wealth so you
got to find ways to invest find ways
um to put yourself in the other right
positions and in contact with right
people
um to help your money grow in in a smart
way and and
and do it the right way got it and so i
know that uh you've got some news for us
today
uh we've been talking a lot about kind
of bitcoin cryptocurrencies i know that
you spent a bunch of time with jack
talk a little bit about uh just how you
see bitcoin
um you know why uh you spent so much
time learning about it and then kind of
what your future plans are
well obviously you see inflation um you
know you see how
how high it is right now and you learn
that you can't save or
save yourself too well you can't um so
that's why
uh i mean i had a little bit of
conversation with jack
one jack this guy is going to change the
world by the way but we'll hop on that a
little bit later
it's a special dude but that's why i'm
gonna be taking my marketing money um in
bitcoin
all right so hold on here this is
important you're gonna be taking 100 of
your marketing dollars which is
by the way you're like a well-known dude
uh people like you brands like you you
do a great job on the marketing side
uh and you make you know eight plus
figures uh in terms of marketing dollars
you're gonna take 100 of that in bitcoin
and specifically try to uh insulate
yourself from all the inflation and the
issues with cash
yeah i'm gonna do that especially
through strike also too um
i feel like uh that was my mind that was
my model before
coming into the league because you know
just live on my marketing money um and
now that i see with inflation and
learning so much about bitcoin
surround myself with a great team and be
able to learn uh from
guys like jack um so i think it's just
be the smart thing to do and the right
thing to do to
start taking my investment money through
bitcoin and through a uh do strike
i i tend to think that this is probably
a pretty good idea jack talk to us a
little bit i know that you spent a bunch
of time with saquon
uh just the conversations you guys have
had what the thought process here is and
then
how strike works in terms of helping him
take 100 of his marketing dollars in
bitcoin moving forward
yeah well you know i'm here compliment
straight back at sequon he's obviously a
tremendous football player but
i hope that the world gets to see the
individual he is he's a leader
he's a trendsetter and this is a huge
move that he's making
and he's setting an example not only for
himself his family his team
but i think for the wider nfl and i
think for all millennials our age
uh the problem that saquon's facing is a
problem everyone faces is that
non-working capital capital that you
want to save capital that isn't required
to spend on your day-to-day life which
is rent which is your phone bill which
is
groceries capital that you want to turn
into generational wealth that you want
to eventually turn into a house or to a
car
you can't save it in cash anymore and
the inflation problem that say quant
hinting at is extraordinarily real
and so then you know instead of asking
why would i buy bitcoin well
where do i put my cash because the more
accurate question to ask and you know
saquon went through this journey on his
own and everyone's doing it currently
i don't know you can try commercial real
estate you can try precious metals and
it turns out bitcoin
is the first asset class that humanity
designed from scratch with our bare
hands
and we as a community built it to solve
this exact
problem and say quan became very
familiar with the problem set the
solution
uh and strike as a company we strive to
develop the best financial experience on
the planet
and i think a core nucleus of that is
access to bitcoin in this way
should we get rewards in bitcoin you
should be able to buy bitcoin for as
cheap as possible you should be able to
take
your direct deposit your everyday
paycheck as the wage that you're earning
uh by dedicating your life to your craft
and
split a certain portion that you want to
save and persist
and grow wealth and protect against
inflation that's exactly what taekwon
did i mean we had conversations about
you know the guys making eight figures
plus annually
in uh off the field in marketing deals
and brand deals
um and it's this capital that he wants
his kids to use his kids have access to
buy a big house with and we talked about
how you know
inflation and housing has reached over
20 right now and so that annually
compounding year over year
that means that his dream house is going
to be twice as expensive in five years
or his cash that he's saving this
marketing deals that is going to be
worth
half his less and he has to start saving
that wealth in something else if he
wants
his dreams his house or his daughter's
tuition
or the toys that she wants for christmas
if he wants those things to be
attainable and achievable
uh he needs to save in something else
and he decided on bitcoin we're more
than happy to support him in that effort
absolutely and so saquon when you think
about this how much of a conversation is
bitcoin cryptocurrencies and stuff like
that in the nfl
other players talking about it um and
what do you expect to be kind of
uh the impact of you making a decision
like this is this now
multiple other people on the team might
do it or just kind of how do you think
about uh
the other players in the league um i
think this is a conversation that's i
don't think i know some conversation
that's been had
in locker rooms but i think it just
starts with just learning
um and i'm still learning and you guys
still learn you guys still understand
um i think jax did an amazing job of
describing it and
um obviously you guys know cuz that's
kind of where it came into i saw it i
was like what is this and you know he
kind of
you know we kind of got into the
conversations of it and talked about it
then i got to be surrounded by a lot
more people that knew much more about it
than myself um i think there's got to be
ways that we could continue to
just educate educate just not just only
athletes but just the world
on bitcoin and what's really going on
and what's the problem in the world
and how bitcoin can really help
absolutely jack explain exactly how this
works in terms of
uh does saquon have to go and
renegotiate his contracts or like
how does it go from he's got these
marketing contracts and endorsement
deals how does he actually get the
bitcoin how to strike work
yeah this is a product that we're
developing and deploying
actively over the next 30 to 60 days to
every consumer in the united states and
that's that you can line up your direct
deposit
product just like you do to chime just
like you do to venmo just like you could
to cash app
uh and you can divide a percent hey of
this paycheck i want 50
of it in bitcoin i want 75 i want 25 of
it in bitcoin
and the mental model that every american
should deploy and everyone in the world
is listen i can't save in cash so listen
you don't like bitcoin fine
i can talk to you about it for hours but
put in something else put in something
else
uh you have to it's trending on twitter
right now right uh and so the product is
very simple it gives you direct access
from your paycheck to saving and
preserving and what
i hold personally and our company holds
is the best savings technology of all
time
uh and being able to build a product for
someone like sequoia i mean say quan's
job
is to be a running back you know let's
say quan his job is not to understand
public key private key cryptography it's
my job
and giving him access to a product that
allows him financial sovereignty
financial independence and an ability to
grow and preserve his wealth
and you know say juan's permission
profession coming off an injury
in the average nfl career is three and a
half years i don't care
what you do that is not enough time in
any profession to build generational
wealth
period and giving guys like him he
deserves it
every american deserves it it's a
foundational human right to have
access to sound money materials to live
a high quality of life
and that's what we want to do and i'm
proud to say juan for this move i mean
it's a really brave thing for him to do
and i think he's setting a huge example
on a big stage obviously
yeah i completely agree all right i got
one last question i'm gonna turn over my
brothers it's a it's a more fun one
two-part question for jack and saquon if
jack and saquon play back one-on-one
basketball right now who wins
me that is so
good that is so wrong it wouldn't even
be close
we've had this conversation before one i
would just use my size
and two he's not fast enough or strong
enough to stay in front of me
i don't even know if he can touch the
rim
i like my chances there what what people
don't know pomp is if i were 6'4 there
would be no strike i'd be in the league
and so you know that was just
you know the mother nature's way of
ensuring that bitcoin progressed in the
way it did by keeping me five eight and
a hundred fifty pounds
um but i still think i could beat
shaequan one on one and uh
do you play like again who you trying to
tell me what's your game like
i'm like steph curry you play like uh
glenn big baby david i'm like steph
curry
all right all right second part of the
question is if jack and saquon sit down
and play
chess who wins uh him
i can't find out he was like some chess
master before like state champion high
school so
um don't don't let them trick you in
into playing the game for
sharing your money on strike it's going
to take all of them saquon
uh we heard a story that somebody said
to jack that they were a chess
master and jack was like oh you're a
chess master they're like yeah he goes
alright cool pawn e4 what's your move
[Music]
[Laughter]
like we don't even need a board we're
just go we're just going to talk it out
right here
all right all right uh joe john what
questions you guys got
um saquon thanks for doing this first
off and congratulations
um they're already they're already
saying in the comments that they're
going to pick you number one overall in
fantasy this year so
so there you go uh but i i think my
question is probably a little bit off of
what you were talking about earlier
which is
what's going on in nfl locker rooms
right and i think uh when you look back
to like the 80s and the 90s in
professional sports a lot of the
conversation was about athletes going
broke and not thinking about
generational wealth and how to build
wealth and investments and stuff like
that and personally i feel like that's
kind of changed more recently right and
you you see
uh you know we've gone out to dinner
with you and other guys and it's kind of
more conversations around investments
and stuff like that
and i'm curious has that been your
personal experience you know when you're
talking to other professional athletes
whether it's in the nfl or the nba or
other leagues around the world
uh are people more concerned about this
stuff are they more interested in it
like how is your feeling about that
i would agree i would say that they're
definitely more uh interested in it and
that's the conversation that are being
had
in the locker room but i said kind of
picking back on what's up before
it's the educational part of it uh that
i see that lacks and including myself
that's why when
i'm with you guys or i'm sitting down in
dinner and i try to ask so many
questions because
um not only i want to learn from myself
when i'm able to go back to the locker
room
i can explain it i can explain it the
right way to my teammates and
um you know your teammates is people
that's gonna be some of your best
friends for life
people that's gonna be at your weddings
um you know brothers for life that's
what as they like to call in football
um so you want to see them succeed too
and the things that i can learn and
things i can educate myself on
um to go there and have the conversation
and and i'm a big believer in
uh playing devil advocate and maybe
someone disagree maybe someone agree
but having those conversations and
seeing both sides um you'll be able to
hear both sides and get somewhere in
your mindset where he's like
all right even if i didn't agree with
this so i don't believe it's going to be
that way
this guy had uh you know educational
background behind it or he said some
some critical things that made me think
and have a different kind of
thought process on this conversation so
i would say education is the big thing
um that that continue needs to have and
in the locker room and
like i said i'll be the first one to say
i got to continue to learn more about it
um but i think we can find more more
avenues and more way to to to help
expand that
for sure john what do you got uh what's
up sequon jack
congrats again um so one of the things i
wanted to ask was about just like your
investments and what you've been looking
at
um you mentioned talking with jack about
how you invested with him
and um also i believe you've done some
stuff in like the sports industry
it seems like you're really open to
doing anything uh
which is great so you're outside of just
like the sports realm and i think guys
like that when they go to kd the lebrons
they know that they're open so lebron's
got the spring hill
katie's got boardroom ventures
everything like that what are you what
are you looking at
um investment wise um
those are the things that where i kind
of want to go to now um is become more
than an athlete
uh you obviously you have your your your
big deals and you know i'm very
fortunate to be able to work
with the big companies like nikes and
such like that um but we want to find a
way to
to get into deals where you can use your
brand to help promote it
um but also help build that brand as you
help go that brand you're building
yourself also
um outside of football um and those kind
of things that i'm looking into and yes
i'm open to anything but
uh that's very another thing i would say
that that is
that happens in locker rooms and with
athletes um there's a lot of things
that's thrown at you it's a lot of
things that's thrown at you
um a lot of investment opportunities of
equity and all that
but you gotta you gotta have the right
team around you um like i said like jack
said my job is to be
a professional football player and be a
dad um
so i don't really have that time as much
as i would like so
i have an amazing team behind me that
we go through every investment every
deal and and really
thoroughly think through it and um we
see what we think is the best
opportunity for me
yeah i'm sure coming coming into the
league there's uh everyone and their
mother's got an idea of where to put
your cash
what to invest in yeah uh
segway you're an investor in strike
right yes sir
all right obviously we both think very
highly of uh of jack
what is the the thing that you think uh
most impressed you about him
and we're going to embarrass him a
little bit here but what what was the
thing that kind of caught your attention
this is hard um to be completely honest
um
he's not in it for uh to make a lot of
money or or be famous
he really want to make an impact and
really change the world um you could see
that the little way he's talked the way
he talked and it conversates you having
him
you can see how passionate he is um and
and those are things that you know
as just a human being you love to see
another human being um so i would say
those that's probably the biggest thing
it's his heart
how passion is and does this man really
want to change the world and he's going
to change the world
i i tend to agree we're going to get him
a a different um
kind of background there but that's fine
jack
are there lots of athletes that are
reaching out to you uh
musicians artists like folks that uh
have high income
and high salaries that are worried about
inflation that are trying to figure out
what
russo kong or uh saquon is doing here or
kind of what are you seeing in that
front
yeah everywhere not only uh athletes but
musicians actors uh you know what i
think is really unique pomp and i
i've heard you i don't know can i call
you pomp because there's a lot of people
as long as you don't call me an [ __ ]
that's fine we're good i won't call you
an [ __ ] you prefer this from
um no but i've heard you say before uh
which is a really interesting point that
you make and it's true that you can't
build wealth as an employee
you've said that before is you got to
own equity you've got to own an asset
if you want to grow well you can't be
working paycheck to paycheck
now that's true except maybe
saquon barkley he's a very valuable
employee he makes a great living right
and you can argue that we'll say quan
runs his own independent business right
and athletes are independent businesses
actors actresses musicians but generally
speaking
what i'm trying to get at is you have
these employees
saquon's an employee near giants and
they pay him handsomely and he's got
making tens of millions of dollars off
the field as well but point being
that he still is subject to getting a
paycheck that his employment is priced
in dollars so say quan signing a
contract that lasts x amount of time
priced in dollars and if you price in
inflation and you price in taxes
he's actually losing like 30 to 70
percent of that money by the completion
of his contract right
and so then he's got all these
commercial real estate agents these club
promoters
his family telling them what cars to buy
what things to invest in
um and i have the opinion that these
people are relatively abused
by their employer and by the people
around them
um that they're taking advantage of and
that they are one of the only rare
employees in america that can
potentially build generational wealth
build an independent business build an
independent brand
leave a legacy like sa quan's worked his
whole life for
and uh that people are getting in the
way of that and that
the nfl and a lot of his counterparts
aren't tremendously honest and
potentially misleading to him
uh and i think it's a real problem and
so i think a lot of the people
contacting me
that is in the nfl in the nba in
hollywood
are starting to realize that starting to
realize like hey i'm making hit after
hit after hit
i'm number one on the billboard every
week but somehow after taxes after
inflation after i listen to my cousin
after i
pay 20 percent off the top to my
commercial real estate broker
i don't have anything left that's
[ __ ] sorry am i allowed to curse
yeah whatever you want i thought it was
that if i
if i make hit after hit or i score
touchdown after touchdown i work my ass
off i
act like a good citizen a good man uh
that i
that this isn't how it works um and i
think everyone is starting to open their
eyes to that
and you know the craze of robin hood and
how bitcoin
is this is a press the federal reserve
has perverted risk tolerance across all
assets no one knows what anything's
worth anymore because no one knows how
to value a dollar
they're more printed by as the seconds
that go by so all that to say
i think every american everyone in the
world faces this problem from a high
level and i think folks like saquon have
a very unique
uh visibility into it because they are
high profile
employees that do make a large wage of
living
and there's a lot of opinions in their
ear and i think bitcoin is the most
accessible way to defend against
inflation it's the most successful way
to protect and preserve wealth it's one
that you can do independently you don't
have to give a real estate broker any
percentage of it
we don't need you guys anymore saquon
can line up his direct deposit
toggle how much he wants to save and
preserve for his daughter and then go
[ __ ] run a linebacker over he doesn't
have to worry about anything else and
that's what it's all about
i completely agree before i let both of
you go
uh saquon the most important question we
have today
the giants gonna win the super bowl are
we gonna win the super bowl this year
um you know that's that's the goal
that's every team's goal is to come out
there and compete for a championship but
it starts with we start camping two
weeks or a week and a half or so
um and it starts there you gotta come
there with the right mindset believe in
each other believe in the coaches
um and take it day by day and and see
where it goes from there you didn't see
this because you're uh only on uh on
zoom but uh we pulled up
saquon barkley and there was before and
we were looking at what we should put
underneath that
and at first we had running back new
york giants we made a audible we said
now you gotta put the true
title we said the best running back in
the nfl so that's exactly what the title
is so we figured that now that you're
coming back from uh
uh the injury you're gonna you're gonna
prove us right so we're super excited
about uh
watching you guys play this year and
obviously uh very excited about the
investment in
strike and uh you know kind of being
co-investors there but uh
i think just from our size just
congratulations you know this is
obviously a huge
decision on your part we tend to think
that uh this is a very smart decision
uh and likely history be very kind to
you but uh it takes real courage to
uh kind of take a step like this and uh
i think people will
you know not appreciate it until uh a
couple years from now
but uh it's pretty cool to see so
congrats again on making this decision
yes sir thank you i appreciate that all
right jack
we'll talk soon my friend yes sir
yeah and i i want to say say juan man
congrats i i
again i spent some time pomp with him
recently a few weeks ago people don't
understand
uh the diligent work that goes into
coming back from an injury like that and
then putting yourself
again in front of 300 pound professional
athletes to get hit
one more time puts a lot of work that
and then also has the time
and peace of mind to put his daughter
and his family in a tremendous financial
position so say quanda you're a
superstar
you deserve all the credit in the world
and i sent a great example for
others to come so congrats dude much
love thanks brother
jack i love you saquon's whooping your
ass in basketball alright guys we'll see
you later